foreign
and so I went on a journey after many
breakdowns in my life in friendships
intimate relationship business
relationships kind of all started
breaking down around the same time about
10 years ago and I realized oh I'm the
jerk that's the common denominator of
all these things
[Music]
good morning good evening good night I
don't know what time it is that you're
listening to this show but this is the
Dr John deloney show and I'm John and
I'm glad that you're with us I hope
you're doing well and hope your family's
well
and hope despite the chaos in the world
you're finding little pockets of peace
today we have a very special show I'm
super hyped for you to be a part of it
um
I was honored and blessed to have the
great Lewis Howes the the host of one of
the largest podcasts on planet Earth and
um he's got a new book out and he came
into the studios to hang out and we
talked for way too long and we went all
over the place and most importantly
um we get to talk about his new book The
greatness mindset unlock the power of
your mind and live your best life today
and just to give you a uh some insight
into how what kind of human Lewis is on
the on the flight over he was in the
airport checking in on his flight he was
coming from Austin and Nashville and he
saw my book in on your past change your
future in the airport
he bought it with his own money I would
have given him as many as he wanted but
he bought it and on the plane right over
he read it
and you'll hear in the interview he
keeps directing the attention away from
his book to mine not because my book is
better you can read his book and you
will find out that is not the case
but that's the kind of guy he is he's
discovered through on his show he
interviews
High performers of all types and when
you talk to him he's like yeah I was
talking to Kobe Bryant once and I was
talking to such such pot Laureate once
and I was talking to the great Gabor
mate a couple times
he has had the opportunity to sit
kneecap to kneecap with some of the most
Brilliant Minds in the world when he's
found that his superpower is Lewis's
superpower is
is shining the light on others is
letting others be seen and that's just
who he is and so this was an important
conversation because he man I told him
off air let's get weird and he goes hold
my beer dude if you want to get weird I
I I I'll call and we talk about
everything everything you can imagine
and here's what's what's really
important
he discusses so much of it in this book
and in this I just can't tell you I
can't recommend this book enough please
go pick it up and check it out
um he takes the wisdom that he has
learned from some of the most important
minds of our time
and some of the most important minds of
ancient history and some of the most
important thinkers about things that are
going to happen in the future and he
puts it all right here and says hey
here's some things you can be doing
right now to live a better life and how
to heal from the past and we we have a
lot of overlap with if you're into this
show you're into on your past change
your future this book is that an
incredible next step for you so sit back
and enjoy my conversation with the Great
and Powerful Lewis house
thank you
see you man thanks for having me brother
appreciate you dude congrats on
everything you're making a big
difference in the world man I appreciate
that you make a humongous difference in
the world I was just telling off off
here this is like uh
uh a high school kid gonna play catch
with Peyton Manning like the best
interview on the planet and uh I'm like
an old academic nerd that's just like
suddenly uh not in a I like the academic
nurse office anymore they have the
science the research the case studies
that you can actually start
yeah and the need to be right at all
times always my way we'll defend it to
the death uh tell me about the tell me
about the journey to get this book out
man well for me it was more about a
journey of discovering myself and I just
felt like I needed to get this out there
because it's been 10 years I've been
doing my show it's full of greatness and
it started with a need a need of I've
accomplished success in sports and in
business but I still don't feel happy
and fulfilled and enough
so how do I figure out this enough-ness
thing this worthiness thing this
deservingness thing of what I'm
accomplishing and also how to navigate
intimacy and relationships along the way
and how to feel worthy of the worth
and so I went on a journey after many
breakdowns in my life in
friendships intimate relationship
business relationships kind of all
started breaking down around the same
time about 10 years ago and I realized
oh I'm the jerk that's the common
denominator of all these things how'd
you get there
man I got him fighting a basketball
court okay like a little fist fight and
it was one of my lower moments where I
remember after this fight thinking the
guy was fine I was fine everything but
it was like a no Stakes basketball game
like do you play basketball at all oh
yeah like pick a basketball I'm
incredible to this I'm not that great
yeah but like so yeah for sure pick up
basketball with a bunch of friends yeah
and uh
I would get so emotionally triggered
when someone would do something that
felt like that was a little unfair
little elbow little smash talk that was
like not clean it was like kind of a
little below the belt you're describing
exactly there was like a button in my
heart that would be like Bing trigger I
want to defend and react and guard
myself against anyone trying to attack
me okay in life yeah yeah so I looked at
the lot the world is like it's me and
then everyone else is out there trying
to get me okay that was how I reacted in
my environments and after this fight
like everything else was breaking down
and that was kind of the final straw I
was like okay I actually physically got
into a fight
something's off with me like why and I
didn't need to defend myself right you
know I was just playing fun on the Mean
Streets of Beverly Hills you know what I
mean right yeah yeah it's like playing a
pickup basketball game in Franklin in
Nashville right it's like there's
nothing that could go wrong so if I pull
that thread all the way where where did
that story begin that you defend
yourself at all costs or this thing
Falls five years old
one of my first memories my third memory
is being sexually abused by a man that I
didn't know in the bathroom okay and
that was just the start right so
that my brother being in prison for four
and a half years when I was eight okay
and visiting the prison almost every
weekend for four and a half years and
just the shame and insecurity and the
the
just the pain that caused the family and
the uncertainty that that caused right
parents really never learning how to
model love with each other they loved us
kids but it didn't feel emotionally safe
at home right and then um just never
feeling good enough in school you know
always in the bottom four of my class
and the insecurity of being in the
special needs classes and just
struggling
so I used that anger that energy that
that wound energy and drove it towards
Athletics gotcha found like I read in
your book which is a fascinating books
you were similar to me this gangly kid
in school which you wrote about
I was like the tall I was six four when
I was like 11. yeah right so but I was
like 105 pounds I've been this big since
seventh grade yeah you're just kind of
like big ears and big teeth and you're
just like this odd kid yeah and um but
if you're fat but if you can play
eventually I could play eventually you
can play and so I I started to get some
validation there and I was like well let
me go all in on this thing because I
have no other skill no other gifts no
other talents in school but in sports
I'm like getting somewhere and I drove
it to say I'm gonna be the best athlete
I can be where I'm going to be
undeniably needed on every sports team
okay
be a star in Every sports team and that
energy drove me to be a great athlete
where I was a All Sport and two uh two
sports
um All State then I was two sport
All-American in college football
decathlon then played Arena Football
professional football then played with
Team USA uh handball with the Olympic
team then transferred that into business
after that was done and just kept
growing and growing growing but every
Milestone I accomplished I still didn't
feel loved so as you're saying that my
time spent with people behind closed
doors or high Achievers you do yours
your images in front of closed doors
mine's been with stuff in Ash right when
you just said growing and growing the
words going through my head was running
and running right chasing and chasing
there you go chasing greatness as
opposed to letting greatness chase me
huh as opposed to letting it come to me
drawing it to me by being intentional in
an alignment with Harmony and peace so I
had
never address the wounds until 10 years
ago and then it's been a 10-year Journey
feelings and whining it's not a
destination that is I'm Healed now it's
an ongoing Journey but 10 years ago was
the moment after this fist fight
I went home in the mirror and kind of
washed the blood off my Knuckles and was
like shaking looking myself in the
mirror and I was I just didn't recognize
who I was and I was like literally
staring one of these literal moments I
was like who are you yeah who's that
dude who are you staring in the mirror
at myself and I just didn't recognize
myself I realized there was so much
anger inside of me resentment fear
insecurity I was really in a a scared
little boy in an adult body and that's a
dangerous person and dangerous man and I
was like man I have a lot to lose here
like what if actually something happened
like really bad in this fight what if I
don't know I hurt myself I heard him
someone came out and stabbed me who
knows I go to jail whatever happens
um
and that was a wake-up call and even
bigger which was one of the greatest
blessings my friend gave me
a friend of mine that I was playing with
that that day
he said Louis I don't like your behavior
and I don't want to play basketball with
you anymore if you're gonna keep acting
like this like he was kind of saying I
don't want to be your friend anymore if
you can't figure out what's going on
within you I love you and accept you but
I don't want to get hurt because of your
actions and behaviors
and that was a big wake-up call that's
when I was finally say okay the world
isn't out to get me it's not everyone
else's problem it's my responsibility to
look within and see why am I so
triggered and reactive in life now I had
love joy no matter fun I was like a fun
guy yeah but man you can poke me yeah
Hulk a little bit I was like you know
it's like there was this guard this sort
of protection these masks that I would
wear to fit in to belong to be accepted
to be seen
but it's so hard to belong and fit into
others if you don't belong to yourself
right if you don't own who you are and
accept your past this is why when you're
when I read this book I was like own
your past I was running away from my
past I was like let alone run away I was
just trying to like that's a culture on
their mind if I can get this car in this
money and this whatever this this this
this then the girl everything right it's
all works the accolades all this stuff
if I can mask with a false sense of
confidence
then I'll be okay but I was never okay
and it's funny have you uh you know Dr
Wayne Dyer have you ever heard of Wayne
Dyer
he passed away a number of years ago but
he was a a big uh speaker and personal
development coach and he used to have
this analogy that said um you know when
you have an orange and you squeeze an
orange what comes out of an orange is
orange juice it's juice it's orange
juice because that's what's inside of an
orange when you squeeze a human being
when you apply pressure to a human what
comes out of a human is what's inside
wow if we have pain unresolved trauma as
you know and talk about this constantly
when that is squeezed and there's
pressure applied to it
anger resentment defensiveness comes out
because that's what's inside of us but
when we learn the strategies that you
teach in your book and what I studied in
my book
you start to mend and heal and create
new meaning from those past memories
then what's inside of you is something
that's more peaceful and in harmony to
your highest self not your hurt self
that's right when your body understands
we weren't okay then but we're okay now
that the adult in you has got has got
the younger you yeah so you talked about
let's going somewhere weird yeah you
said I like to go weird places yeah
two years ago I started on the Journey
of healing to the next level different
wounds ten years ago it was the sexual
abuse and kind of healing that
psychological emotional memory and wound
yeah
because for 25 years on Intel sold this
happened to me and the things we conceal
has power over us there's actually uh in
the I just I just pulled it out but
there was a chapter and it's something
new I'm working on called the biology of
Secrets and I don't believe our bodies
are designed like up until just a few
years ago we all lived in one room house
like this right and everybody everyone
knew Secrets yeah and this idea that I
can go in a room and shut the door and
put podcast hit like and just have this
internal world that's new to our species
right and so yeah like was it is it
Stocker brown brene brown says shame eat
secrets for breakfast right that old
yeah when you hold on to it when we
conceal those past pains those things
have power over us so for 25 years
I was powerless to this shame this
insecurity this fear this doubt this
thing that
um I was afraid that if anyone knew this
about me no one would accept me and love
me
because I didn't accept me in love
that's right and so for me it became a
process of
going back two years ago to
every memory that caused any pain and
the emotional coach that I was working
with had me put a photo of my
five-year-old self from that time on my
screen saver I don't have it anymore but
I had it for about six months every time
you know 50 100 times a day I'm looking
at my five-year-old self now let's talk
about weird because I know this is where
you like to go this is the nerdy stuff
that you like to dive into
I did this and I didn't just have a
photo myself and say okay it's nice to
look at myself I practiced every week
with a coach a guide
to navigate all the different areas of
those emotional memories that caused me
pain
and I started to create
a healing energy with my current self
the adult self in the room now with that
child so what I did I did some weird
stuff weird exercises and I'm all about
the physical exercises needed to release
trauma and to man to create meaning
that's right so one of the things I did
she said I want you to go home and I
want you to pray and meditate
for a period of time and get yourself in
a calm meditative state
and then I want you to imagine and call
forth the five-year-old version of
yourself close your eyes and see him
coming up to you and just notice him
notice his energy notice his awkwardness
notice his unsecurities his fears his
doubts notice how he's clenching himself
notice all the things about him that
you're you're seeing that you felt 35
years ago
and I want you to have a conversation
with him from the person you are today
of what he needed to hear back then
and so I was imagining this again I'm
going there I don't know if this is what
your audience is into but I was like
going there and having this conversation
with my five-year-old self and I was
like
I'm so proud of you you're so courageous
what you're experiencing is not what
people are supposed to experience but
it's all going to be okay and I've got
you now I've got us now
and I did this conversation this kind of
process with myself while literally
visualizing my you know little self
right in front of me
and then again I'm going a little weird
here I after I had this full
conversation I said how do you feel
what's going on what do you need and I
just kept saying is there anything else
kind of like a therapist would say is
there anything else like what else you
need tell me everything
and I said I'm so proud of you because
you're able to take us to where we are
now you overcame it you endured it
but holding on to that doesn't serve us
anymore
so I brought my little self spiritually
metaphorically into my heart and just
gave him a big hug
and embraced him
and then I just kept practicing kind of
this this new story and belief and
meaning around looking at this you know
little boy that was me and is me he just
said man I'm proud of you and I created
a new relationship with those years of
uncertainty and fear and I started doing
that from a five-year-old self to 12
year old self to 17 year old self until
I brought it all the way to now so all
the different painful things from our
past again own your past you can't own a
part of your past and look over other
parts all of your past if you want
freedom if you want peace you know this
better than anyone
and all the research that I've done from
all these great neuroscientists
therapists spiritual leaders uh uh
mental health experts they all talk
about healing all parts of your past if
you want freedom yes
and I had healed certain parts when I 10
years ago but not every part so I got
some freedom but I was still having like
what is it like because I've seen grown
men
um so yes we have like a we have a great
gang that follows me all all down those
rabbit holes I love so it's not too bad
no no no no no
me ask it this way I've seen grown men
get catatonic during those moments or
weep in a way that the most common
phrase I hear is if I if I start crying
I'm never gonna stop yeah man it's scary
or maybe it was a peaceful moment and
not everybody let me take you back to
the moment where I actually told someone
for the first time okay
it was terrifying to to realize to say
the words out loud it was terrifying I
thought I was gonna die okay emotionally
yeah obviously physically it feels like
you're physically like
um because you think or let me speak for
myself I thought if anyone knows this
about me they will never accept me and
love me again and I'll be alone forever
and die alone that's kind of like how
far the rap it goes
and so after this fight happened I was
like okay let me take a look in the
mirror and see what can I learn now as a
cocky 30 year old who thought he knew
everything already in life because I was
successful in sports because I got
results in business I was like
what can you guys tell me teach me you
know like I've gotten results you
haven't got results don't tell me what I
need to change because it's very
defensive look at the scoreboard ego
yeah ego attitude that doesn't serve me
right
um
I started to say okay I'm gonna start
asking questions to people I'm gonna
start looking for a coach therapist I'm
gonna start finding spiritual leaders
I'm gonna go workshops whatever people
recommend me like I'm gonna ask for
feedback and I'm gonna go do it and I
went to this one emotional intelligence
leadership Workshop
and it was like two weekends back to
back like four days each weekend
and in the second week I did it there it
got pretty intense it was pretty
intensive like going into your past
doing exercises with like individuals
small groups like playing games
exercises to reenact situations in life
and then reflect and journal on what
these things taught you and how you
reacted in the kind of the workshops
that's a hot room dude hot room right
it's a hot room there was so after like
the halfway mark of the second weekend
we had did a lot of intense stuff like
talk about Mom and Dad and past pains
and wounds and and all these different
things like just going there screaming
catharsis and all this stuff journaling
reflecting people are crying sharing
and the trainer says okay
we have addressed the past and we are
creating a vision of the future that we
want to create and so we're going to
start working towards our future and
we're not going to think about the past
we're we're going to focus on a vision
and a mission and how you want to show
up in the world as your authentic self
and creating your identity that is
healthy and all these things but in
order to do that we must make sure we've
gone through everything in the past we
must essentially own our past
so if anyone has anything left to say
that you haven't said yet
it's kind of like now is your moment or
forever hold your peace and I'm going
through my head we're all sitting there
in kind of like a half circle
um with like an open space at the front
and I am uh I'm sitting and I'm kind of
like it's silent for like a minute I'm
like okay I talked about you know my
parents getting divorced and struggling
there I talked about being picked on and
being bullied and you know being picked
last in sports teams in elementary
school which drove me um talked about
like breakups from girlfriends that hurt
me and like the sadness I felt
all that stuff and I was like
why have I never told anyone this one
thing that comes up in my mind almost
every day
and I just thought to myself I was in a
a state of like vulnerability people
were opening a safe environment after a
couple weekends where I was like okay
it just came to me I was like if I don't
share this now I may keep this to my
grave yeah I may never say this like
it's you know now or never
and whatever reason I just like got up
out of my chair I walked to the front of
the room and I remember
I put my face down it was like a carpet
and everyone was in like a half
semi-circle around sitting and I
remember I couldn't look up on anyone's
eyes I had so much shame so much shame
so I looked down the whole time
and I just took a deep breath and I
walked through the entire story of being
five and being sexually abused by the
babysitter's son for the first time this
like adult son
and I told the whole story and I was
able to get through it like pretty calm
I think because I didn't look up at
anyone
and then I like walked back to my seat I
sit down I like sit up and look up
there's a woman two women sitting on
either side of me in the chairs they're
weeping they both clinch me and hug me
and for whatever reason I was one of
those guys that just started like
releasing 25 years of pain sadness anger
resentment and just started bawling yeah
balling weeping yeah
and the Weeping and the crying made me
feel shameful and I felt shameful
thinking like oh my gosh this is my life
is over I literally after a few moments
run out of the room we're in the middle
of a workshop I run out of the room
it's in like a conference Ballroom in a
hotel I run outside of the hotel into
like the back alley there's a wall I put
my head on my hand uh and just kind of
lean against the wall and I'm just
weeping crying I'm just like I can't
breathe
few minutes go by and I'm just thinking
I'm not going back in there I'm done
this is like my life's over it feels
like you're dying this grieving process
I feel the top of my shoulder a few
minutes later
this guy turns me around he looks me
dead in my eyes he's probably like 55 60
years old he looks at me he goes you're
my hero
you're my hero
I was 11 when this happened to me I've
got a wife and three kids they don't
know I've been suffering for however
many years married with this I didn't
think I'd ever tell anyone you gave me
permission to tell me I get chills
thinking about this because
and then a bunch of other men came out
and a couple it was only a couple of the
guys that experienced some type of
sexual abuse
but it was like so many men had
something else that they were holding on
to they weren't sexual abused but it's
like I feel shame around this I feel
shame around this and I've never told
anyone and I was just like what I
thought first off I was the only one in
the world who had been sexually abused
and so I thought I was something wrong
with what's wrong with me
and the more I started to study and
research at one in six men have been
sexually abused right
it's one in four with women I still
don't believe that one in six number I
think it's more it might be that's me
yeah that's like 10 that are willing to
talk about it right
and um
but this was in this was 10 years ago
when I opened up about it I had never
seen
whether I wasn't willing to acknowledge
it when I saw it I don't remember seeing
anyone talk about it on TV like men I
don't remember athletes opening up or
singers or you know Role Models being
like oh this is what happened to me
Business Leaders no one talked about
these things back then and we're
starting to see men Now open up more
athletes are starting to open up people
are talking about these things but um I
just thought my life was over but that
was the moment my life began that's
right that was the moment where it
unlocked the ability to start feeling
freedom I didn't feel free yet but it
opened the door for peace to come in and
that was the start of a what has been
now a 10-year
learning trying mistakes growing falling
back two steps moving forward getting in
alignment you know healing trying lots
of different modalities from again
workshops to I'm talking medit deep
meditation retreats in India to
Neuroscience meditation Retreats with Dr
Joe dispenza too
um you know extreme breathing and cold
therapy with Wim Hof in Iceland climbing
mountains half naked in the snow being
pelted by uh by snow and doing breathe
breath work and meditation and
mindfulness and cold therapy like from
emotional coaches to spiritual coaches
and trying everything yeah and I don't
think there's one thing that is the
end-all be-all I think it's like do
whatever you can do to create and be
peace and free inside of you so it's
been a journey man but that was kind of
when it started to open up
that's awesome thanks for bravery on
sharing that of course um as you
mentioned the number of people who are
listening to this
The Men Who will hear it and say
maybe I can say it out loud and maybe
the women listening to this can say it
out loud or they can turn and look
to the person they're dating or married
to and say
is there any stories you know I mean it
it just needs somebody to go first and I
and I'm not saying you need to say it
publicly and I'm not saying you need to
say it to your partner right away right
then create an environment where you can
say it to a trusted advisor that's right
a counselor a therapist a priest a
spiritual leader someone you truly trust
first to allow you to start processing
it do not process it alone I just think
that's the hardest thing to do and near
impossible it's impossible the the great
David Kessler says grief demands a
witness and I I love that line just like
the it only works if I'm with that's why
every every great religion over time has
confession built into it you got to sit
with somebody else and say this happened
I know right and we've kind of taken
that out right and I just think when we
conceal past shame and pains it makes us
more powerless right as opposed to
stepping into a greatness mindset and
that's just one of the elements so it's
first like recognizing where are the
areas of my life that I am allowing
powerlessness to rule me as opposed to
peace and greatness to inspire me so how
do you do that when the the cultural
wins are so opposite back
the wrong way there yeah man I mean I
don't know about you but I grew up in
the 80s in Ohio and uh playing sports
you couldn't show any emotions no on the
field off the field there was no room
ounce of emotion was like okay we're
gonna name call you we're gonna pick on
you we're gonna like call you a little
wussy or whatever we're gonna like
Haze you for months and so it was always
a mask it was always rub the dirt on it
like don't show your emotional don't
show you cry don't show anything
so it wasn't
unlearning of a model that I experienced
that served me to get certain results
but didn't create Freedom inside of me
and so it was but it's both the end
right like you got to feel it
and experience and then go do it go just
go do the next right thing you gotta do
the next right that's the integration
right that's hard you know it's asking
someone to live the Paradox right it's a
doctor and a mental health coach you
know that integration is how you really
heal it's the awareness of okay okay I'm
Awakening to this idea that wow I I've
struggled this whole time in this or
I've been afraid to do this thing
a lot of times we're unconscious of it
it's just happening but okay now I'm
conscious of this I'm aware
now I've got to process this thing I've
got to allow myself to to release it in
some way you know that can be physical
emotional spiritually like connecting
with someone however you want to release
it
um and then allowing yourself to
integrate the nervous system healing
when the response happens again I don't
know if you've ever been triggered in
life where someone like poked something
on you and you're like you're reactive
right or you felt like oh that didn't
feel good
I don't think the goal is to never like
not feel a range of emotions but when
our emotions are running our decisions
and we're reactive based on a wound
right it just means it's pulling our
energy away from service it's pulling
energy away from love and connection and
generosity right I call it the Gap if if
I can just lengthen that gap between
I just film this and whatever I'm about
to do next it's between say it feel it
whatever yeah if I can just stretch that
Gap a little That's it man yeah so it's
uh my my intention is how do I keep
learning and integrating
how to make sure my nervous system is
safe with me no matter what happens
around me
all right people all of us procrastinate
about something maybe you've been
ignoring your check engine light or
maybe you've been putting off plans to
read more whatever it is good sleep is
not something to put off sleep is the
foundation for your mental and physical
health and like your check engine light
your old mattress won't just fix itself
so don't procrastinate here quality
sleep starts with a great mattress like
dream cloud with their one year in-home
trial there's no excuse to keep tossing
and turning on your old mattress that
keeps getting more uncomfortable by the
night
it's time to invest in good sleep and
dream cloud is the only luxury brand
that gives you a full year to try out
your new mattress a full year stop
procrastinating I know you'll love your
dream club right away just like my
family does right now dream cloud is
offering my listeners 25 off your order
plus 50 in additional savings and why
not
599 dollars in accessories with promo
code John deloney that's pillows luxury
sheets and a mattress protector so go on
dreamcloudsleep.com and use promo code
John deloney today and also probably
don't ignore that check engine light for
very much longer
at what point
does okay so you're somebody I've
watched from afar
and I've actually had this thought over
and over
does that guy go home every day and be
like well I gotta do this one now like
because you you you on your show
you're talking to high achiever After
High achiever After High achiever After
High achiever and as soon as I meet a
high achiever I'm always like well I'm
gonna try that too I want to try that
too and I I I've thought without ever
knowing you got to be exhausting like
every ride home has to be like well I
guess I need to move everything to
crypto and the next one you're like well
I guess I need to move everything back
into cash and I need to try this workout
let's work out this workout
here's the question I'm beginning to ask
myself
very similar I haven't been to to uh to
uh India or Iceland but yeah but have
followed very similar yes
you just go to the university and study
like a research exactly I sit in my pool
tub which is a uh like a like a a trivia
science room and just a trough I bought
at a tractor supply for 100 bucks
um
at what point are we running still we've
just found a new thing to chase I don't
think it's running I think it's
um our pursuit of yeah I think it's
trying things on and seeing what works
for us okay it's I'm always because I
struggle with that because I'm always
going with this idea if I got to get
somewhere to the next level or the next
layer whatever words you want to use and
I'm starting to step back and look at
some of the great thinkers that I still
read now and they almost had a
de-evolution process right it almost
went the other way well I don't think
there's fulfillment without growth okay
I think we've got to be growing in some
way that could be learning that could be
reading that could be
um you know trying new skills it could
be playing games and like doing stuff
we've got to be growing in some way I
think in order to feel fulfillment and
feel like okay I'm I'm do I'm not being
complacent okay I'm not saying you have
to always be striving for the next thing
but I think growth and contribution are
a huge part of fulfillment when I'm
learning when I'm growing and developing
as a human
and I'm also contributing to someone
else's life there's a lot more
fulfillment in that process as opposed
to I've stopped growing I'm not growing
at all I'm just going to stay where I'm
at and not learn anything new not try
anything new and I'm just going to do
exact same things that's the thing that
haunts me is there a moment when growth
becomes cancer right when it's obsessive
growth yeah yeah but if it's tied to
what is it tied to your contributions
so it's grow I mean it's contribution
service for me it's all about service
but
and so when I'm doing interviews
and I'm
learning new things a lot of it's just
confirming that I'm doing the right
things okay that I'm on the path that
like okay you're just saying something
in a different way that I'm already
doing good I think for someone like me
and others we need constant reminders to
stay on track of doing the right things
no you know it's like a lot of us I got
it right a lot of us know what to eat
and that's going to make you healthy
they know how to work out right they
know they need to move their body and
eat well and sleep better as a a night
and get good rest but for whatever
reason we don't follow through on it
consistently right as a society based on
results
so it's just about having the consistent
lessons the inspiration the the wisdom
hurt in a different way to keep me on
track of like okay I'm I'm doing the
path I'm being consistent I'm being
disciplined on the path that I'm taking
and it's like oh let me try this
different style of breathing technique
maybe that can help me in a stressful
moment okay I'm gonna try this box
breathing technique that's a 60-second
thing and try it on maybe it works maybe
it doesn't people can say a lot of
different things to try these things and
maybe there's like okay I haven't tried
this thing yet or I just forgot
that I'm not I haven't done this in a
while and I need to get back to this
thing you know what I mean but that
almost makes it equal as important as
the info
the relationship 100 like the
interaction 100 man and that's what you
talked about in your book The Story of
relationships I think it was that
chapter connection which is about like
you have friend you have like people you
text but they're not your close friends
anymore you have people that were like
friends
but an in-person interaction became a
phone call became a text between became
a I'll get back to you later yeah and um
it's about the interactions we have with
the people in our lives and how we're
making an impact and being in service to
those people to them being empowered and
winning as well and that's the
difference between success and greatness
success success is self-servation yeah
it's all about me let me accomplish this
let me achieve this goal let me win let
me look good let me be a bestseller
there's nothing wrong or bad with the
success but success by itself without
the impact and service to others in that
Pursuit will leave us feeling it's
unfulfilled yeah so greatness is more
about going after your dreams with your
unique gifts and talents in the season
of life you're in
but empowering those around you and the
great Kobe Bryant said this when I
interviewed him he was like greatness is
about
essentially being an inspiration to the
people around you and inspired them to
be great and when they are great they're
going to inspire others to be great and
it's about that Ripple that impact of
service through your talent through your
gift through your creativity and
whatever that is and and I realized that
most of my life was being successful for
me to feel good
yeah it was a win-lose mentality yep and
nobody wins unless everyone wins right
right and I didn't understand that
concept until 30 until I had breakdown
after breakdown after breakdown and I
learned for the first time the concept
of win-win at 30. as an athlete growing
up there was only one winner and
everyone else was a loser and that meant
when I lost it didn't feel good yeah and
I did everything to win
things that that like I just drove
myself crazy to win and then I still
didn't feel enough and that's when I
started shifting 10 years ago I created
a show called the school of greatness
that wasn't about me it was about others
and I said I'm gonna go on a journey and
humble myself and I'm going to interview
all the experts and Shine the Light on
others and just ask questions and humble
myself and it's been a decade of
consistently doing that and that the
picture there that you're painting is is
beautiful when it comes to greatness
because I'm hearing in this one
conversation
very few people can say when I was
talking to Kobe that one time
but there's greatness on the basketball
court and there's greatness that his
legendary greatness in the gym right
like behind closed doors so nobody's
watching
and then there's greatness of Life a
young man yeah rocking back and forth
and put his head down and walking up to
front of a small group and saying this
happened yeah right and it's that it's
everywhere in between right and the The
Men Who went home and talked to their
families for the first time or talk
called the counselor for the first time
right greatness the spectrum is so
powerful yeah right that Ripple effects
it doesn't matter the the the magnitude
of what you want to do in life it's not
greatness is not about curing cancer or
winning a world championship it's about
pursuing your unique gifts and talents
and in that Pursuit making a difference
on the people around you in a positive
way it's not about
even accomplishing the pursuit although
yes we want to accomplish our goals and
things like that
but just because the dreams don't come
true sometimes doesn't mean your life
and the experience wasn't a dream come
true doesn't mean what you learned in
the process wasn't a dream yeah yeah
it's amazing man so we got to learn to
um interpret it and have a different
perspective around what it looks like
and also know that we are all in
different seasons of life and you might
be in one season
for three months or two years that you
don't want to be in but you're trying to
get out of and then it's going to expand
to something bigger and greater for the
next season but you needed that
challenging season to get to the next
stage and the The Challengers to hang on
hang on because the next stage is coming
right
[Music]
hey good folks John deloney here I
I fell through a glitch in The Matrix
this is my job I get to have this show
do this show walk alongside each one of
you as a career this is what I do and I
have a blast doing it and me and the
team were so thankful for all of you for
being a part of our show whether you're
one of the original 17 or you're one of
the millions that's come since then we
are so grateful for you and we want to
put together the best possible show that
we can so if you're one of The Originals
or if you're brand new we want your
feedback tell us what you love about the
show what you hate about the show would
you like to see more of what you like to
hear more of and what you want us to
never do again you can email us at
askjohn ramseysolutions.com that's ask
John
ramseysolutions.com with your feedback
thank you for being such an important
part of the show rock on
all right so let me get to your book
here
um
phenomenal thank you phenomenal
um and we were talking off air
it makes me feel happy because I'm super
I'm super insecure and
the fact that you've got to meet all
these great people that I just revered
through their work man and you did such
a great job this is the Masterpiece it's
awesome thank you
um so I'm gonna tell you some things
that as I
went through this yeah
you have a story where you broke your
wrist when you were on the verge of
you're playing Arena Football League yep
and you're with dreams of aspirations of
going NFL yep and you broke your wrist
ended up being a more serious break and
while you're at home like any athlete
who's been laid up
there's that
a little bit of doubt and a little bit
of I could I'll be back and then that
little bit of like people like hey are
you still playing and you're like no man
I'm hurt but I'm cut like there's all
that right and if you're an athlete you
get that world
then your dad gets in yeah a
life-altering car wreck yep okay big
brain injury yeah here's where my head
went so I spent most of my career
showing up to that situation either to
tell Lewis hey this just happened or
with the family right yeah so when I'm
reading this part in your book
here's here's with the hook into my
heart tell me about being a son a strong
powerful pro football player yeah right
right which puts you in the top one
percent of the top one percent
and
there's this moment we all have when our
dads are suddenly
powerless yeah
take me back there as this you can't go
overseas so he was on vacation he was in
New Zealand and I have just broken three
ribs the next day at a football game so
I couldn't travel first can't travel
yeah and then he comes back and there's
that shape-shifting moment where I can
do all things I can lift I can do the
225 bench workout I can do all that
I can't fix that no man it was
devastating take me back there it was
sad man I remember him coming off the
plan we were at the airport waiting for
him to come back
and it's kind of like being helped to
walk you can't fully really walk by
himself but he's kind of hobbling off of
like the airport coming towards the exit
and I give him a hug and it was the
moment I was like oh man
he's a completely different person like
mentally emotional well like mentally
emotionally psychologically personality
wise he's different
and I was like okay
well he's gonna come back you know he's
gonna get better
and I remember just year after year it
was a struggle man he didn't he he got a
little bit better
but his personality almost completely
changed not because he wanted it to but
the brain trauma was so intense that it
just messed up the chemicals in her
brain and he just
so it was very challenging every time
I'd go and see him we'd say
what's your name oh man uh oh it's right
Lewis yeah
um used to play sports right what what
sport did you play again where did you
go to school
and here's a man who went to almost
every one of my games he was on the
field taking photos was like championing
me like celebrating me all the time in
athletics he was there he showed up
for him to not even know that I used to
play sports and have to constantly for
17 years he used to be like
where'd you go to school again so I have
to show them photos and remind him he
goes oh yeah okay yeah you play football
right and oh yeah but it was just man
it's just hard when you're used to
seeing something with someone you know
your father and he's not that anymore
it's like he almost it's like he died
that's right emotionally but he uh
physically was there I've had someone
describe maybe one of the most
heart-wrenching heartbreaking
conversation I've ever had with someone
explaining what it's like when a parent
has Alzheimer's Alzheimer's yeah man
like so hard and to have your mom look
at you and not know your name it was
it's disorienting it's really and it's
it's traumatizing yeah it's it affected
all I have three siblings and I'm the
youngest of four so it's
it impacted all of us in different ways
and we all experience pain in other in
certain ways
and at the same time
it
it helped Define me into wanting to make
an impact and serve people in a bigger
way so I wish it didn't happen but at
the same time
I eventually after about four or five
years
accepted it because it was going to
drive me mad because I kept trying to
change it half or like what can I
do to make this what doctor can I call
who can I get him on a program and we
just need to teach him more we need you
know trying to force something and
realizing like
he's got a different purpose he can't
work he can't cook he can't drive he
can't do anything he sits there and he
doesn't want to have a drive anymore he
was a big loving happy driven smart man
and the Brain just so affected that it's
different now it's different and
accepting him where he's at was one of
the hardest things accepting your father
not recognize you accepting him and just
loving him with his new purpose for this
season
and I never was able to really grieve
though because he was still alive yeah
he passed a year ago okay I'm sorry to
hear that thank you yeah thank you and
it was it was like the first time I
could grieve after 17 years of his first
death his emotional and mental deaths
but last year he physically passed
and I finally allowed myself to kind of
I like accepted it before
but it was almost like I could finally
have a have a different relationship
with him now where I couldn't have them
for 17 years now I feel like I have a
true spiritual relationship with him
right
and it's um
it's been part of the healing grieving
process you know as I don't think I've
fully grieved while he was alive even
though he was here right yeah so that
was uh he was traumatic man but um you
know we all have different traumas Big T
Little T as you know
and we all have something to face yeah
and that was just the thing that I
needed to face and you talked about how
you know a lot of people run away from
their I think I can remember the story
of death or story or something but it
was like right have a culture we've
running away from it hiding it not
talking about it right Outsource at all
right yeah I love that chapter about
that because
you know some of the happiest people in
the world think about their death
multiple times a day that's right I
think it's the country of Bhutan that
that practices five times a day thinking
about their that's right that's right
yeah yeah and they focus I don't think
they're the very stages of them in the
in the grave but they're just like okay
and there's an app uh that a friend told
me about called we croak and it's an app
that five times a day it tells you
you're gonna die
and and the whole point of it and then
it has like an inspiring quote so make
sure you like appreciate what you have
right now so be in gratitude so kiss the
person you love it's a reminder of like
life is now
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible and each person's situation
is unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
I think when I asked Kobe about his
relationship with his father I said what
do you think made you great he said my
parents told me they were going to love
me whether I scored every point or no
points and he said one summer in
basketball like when he was 12 or 13 he
was in a summer league practicing
playing in a tournament for months he
said he did not score one point
and his dad and his mom were just like
we love we still love you we love you no
matter what we just want you to have fun
and he said it gave him permission to go
out and be great yeah and I kind of love
anchors you into Bedrock so you can
repel off right and you can do crazy
wild stuff and this goes back to uh
after I opened up about the sexual abuse
in this Workshop I remember thinking to
myself okay these people in this group
accepted me because we were all kind of
opening up about different stuff
so they you know they're strangers okay
you know who cares what happens they're
safe but I was like I don't think I can
tell my family or my friends I don't
think they're gonna accept me I talked
to a therapist friend of mine and I was
like hey this thing just happened I just
talked about this and I'm actually
really scared because I don't know if
anyone else will accept me
can I even bring this to family and
friends
and she gave me a great piece of advice
she said
a time to call them each individually
and ask them a question first and see
their reaction and then see how you feel
about it but ask them is there anything
I could ever say or do that would make
you not love me
and based on the response
if you feel comfortable then you can
share
if they receive that and if they say
yeah absolutely not and I did that with
each one of my family members I said is
there anything you could ever say I
could ever say or do to make you not
love me and they're all like absolutely
not doesn't matter what you've done I'm
still gonna love you and it gave me
permission to reveal myself it gave me
permission to open up and be honest
about my shames and insecurities
and then I thought to myself okay well
these are my family they have to accept
me but my friends I don't know if they
will but it was a practice of going down
and because I still felt powerless if
other people knew this about me they
wouldn't accept or love me and I think
that's where it all comes back to but I
I what you did was really important and
I hope the listeners hear this
we have a again we live in such
polarized world but we either have
people who sit on on Secrets forever
yeah or we've got pathological
overshares yes right you're like hey
screaming vulnerability yeah and then
one time and you're like dude like and
so it's context setting it's time and
place magic which is
you knocked said can I come in yes and
they said come on in if they're not
ready for it if they're making a joke or
like ah what are you gonna say you're
crazy and then maybe don't tell them
yeah exactly and maybe they're not
they're not ready for it maybe they're
not ready for it yeah don't spew it on
everyone there you go yeah and I'm not
saying you need to share with everyone
in your life these things but I think
it's important yeah you got to share it
with someone right yes and if not and it
means you're unwilling to let people see
inside of you
okay why is this harsh to say it this
way
um
if you're unwilling to let somebody to
have that conversation
they're in my head and man tell me I'm
wrong you can hit me even there's comes
a moment when
you're choosing to stay here then
to stay stuck or stay in that past yes
and it and it pains me to to look at
somebody's experienced abuse experience
trauma experience marginalization and
say
from this point forward
you're choosing to stay here for a
season and that's okay you're free to do
that it's just more powerlessness it's
just you're powerless oh that thing has
power over you still yeah if you're
unwilling to reveal something or share
something or talk about something
because you're so afraid then you're
letting fear run your life yeah as
opposed to healing and peace and
acceptance of who you are or what you've
been through and here's the thing I am a
big believer I'm assuming you'll agree
with this that
the the secret to a happy life is
relationships and the secret to happy
relationships is vulnerability
dude I wish I wish there could be any
other way any other way yeah I wish you
could just fake it and just make
everything a joke and like you know dude
rub off the past and not talk about it
just have a long text thread of funny
memes yeah that was it which has been
your life it sounds it's everyone's life
is not there's not and when I had these
conversations with my family members
and I opened up what do you think
happened they all started to be like
they all shared something about
themselves that I didn't know and it
created a bond a connection of like wow
I respect I trust you I appreciate you
more like this connection more I think
you could even flip that we also have a
pathological inability to say the good
stuff that's going on and we downgraded
right oh dude but like let's say you
cross a billion downloads or whatever
the threshold is yeah
do you have four or five people you
could spook the phone and call and they
would go dude that's all right you know
I said it's all the good stuff too also
when it says you haven't interviewed a
lot of people on your show right yeah
yeah I just take calls I've interviewed
a lot of
some of the most famous people
successful people billionaires you know
world champion athletes whatever
um
and there's something interesting that
happens almost I don't know 90 95 of the
time at the end of every episode
from the beginning I always acknowledge
people at the end from what I see in
them after I enter the interview them
for an hour or two I sit there and I'm
like I want to acknowledge you for this
gift that I see in you
number one most people are can't receive
acknowledgment they don't they don't
receive
praise and celebration or acknowledgment
that well you want to know what most
people say at the end when the camera is
done and the lights are off and the mic
shut off
but come to me and say
was that good
is that good enough yeah was that was
that okay
and I'm like you're freaking this person
you're desperate you're like
give me some of your talent yeah I'm
like what was it good it was incredible
but it's like we still feel like we need
this
did I say everything the right way
should I set it this way it's like this
need to be still accepted and like am I
enough am I enough okay before we leave
yes you wrote this and I give it to you
right this last question
said
here's the thing about greatness
greatness is not about being complete at
the start it's about being enough even
while you're still growing developing
and changing and as I read that
here's where the tension comes in you
already are enough when you're in this
moment and you're always becoming more
I don't think our culture has a
psychological understanding of the word
enough no because most people are never
satisfied so how do you balance growing
in enough
this is the thing with high Achievers
too it's like
the because they'd never been satisfied
that's what's Driven them to get the
results they're at and so they're like
well I don't want to be satisfied
because I'm not going to have this chip
on my shoulder I'm not going to have
this drive or this hunger to go for more
and then what then I might lose it all
my Edge my Edge right and here's the
thing
you know the enemy of greatness is
lacking a meaningful mission in a
meaningful mission
[Music]
is not just about your success for your
benefit it's about your success in the
service of others as well
and when we Define clearly this is the
difference between a greatness mindset
and a powerless mindset when you define
a meaningful Mission which includes
others
you have a renewable energy and you
don't want to stop
and you don't feel like you're burning
out
like I'm on this when it's in service to
somebody else it's in service to others
you might have moments of like okay I'm
exhausted like I'm in a season of like
you know foreign abuse today and
traveling on no sleep but I'm doing it
in the service of others not for me to
look good
and now I'm going to need to go back and
rest and recover and all these things
but I don't feel burnt out I feel
excited every day about what I'm doing
because the mission is Meaningful to me
and it's not about me it's about
including service to other people in the
process so when I measure my worth
based on service to others and my
generosity of my energy my attitude my
effort not on the success of the results
I feel a lot better about me because it
doesn't determine how many books I sell
or how many downloads I have or how many
followers I have determines did I show
up today in service to my mission and if
I did that I am satisfied with my effort
today I am enough today
did I accomplish the mission no so let
me get back up and keep growing and keep
serving but I'm at peace with who I am
and the efforts I have in this moment
dude this has been one of the most
important conversations of my life and
um I could show you here on my uh
garment that my heart rate's lower but
um
there's some hard conversations I need
to have and I want to thank you because
you were willing to have those hard
conversations and come here and help me
be a little more peaceful that's going
to help me be a better dad my little
girl to my son and to my wife yeah
definitely not her dad she's more than
my mom but I'm gonna be a good husband
um so I want to thank you for your time
of course you don't get this hour back
of your life and you shared it with me
and I'm grateful for you thank you
brother thank you thank you bro
foreign